you
[Music]
[Music]
rhyme feels a little like someone
telling you the only way you can see the
Mona Lisa is by unlocking a really heavy
safe the painting is beautiful sure but
my god why did you make seeing it so
bloody difficult although rhyme looks
and sounds gorgeous it's visual splendor
is locked behind frustrating shallow
puzzles and a confusing story meaning
you spend more time figuring out where
to go than taking in the world around
you
much like journey or Eiko rhyme features
no text and only a basic unfamiliar
language your blank slate child
character communicates through
nondescript calls and facial expressions
similarly there's no hints or heads up
this way and ingame cues are portrayed
through abstract audio-visual signals
such as cave paintings and animal cries
[Music]
when the game opens with your character
waking up on an unfamiliar Island the
absence of these typical gameplay themes
lends rhymes environment a sense of
mystery you'll wonder where you are how
you got there and what you're supposed
to be doing and you'll want to explore
the island to discover the answers this
is Ryan at its best the first of four
worlds is a mini sandbox of places I
wanted to go animals I wanted to pet and
objects I wanted to touch the wind in
the trees and the distant sound of
wildlife in addition to a slow classical
soundtrack and no enemies or time
pressure makes it a pleasant relaxing
experience a bit like taking a walk
around a summer park
[Music]
in one beautiful sequence you have to
illuminate a caves darkened floor
beneath you using your singing voice at
times rhyme is magical
before long you'll come across the
game's first puzzles which mostly
involves shouting to release bursts of
energy that activate platforms and doors
these puzzles are expanded upon later in
the game as light manipulation and
pressure plates are added into the mix
but even when more mechanics are added
the puzzles remain simplistic to the
point of being shallow the majority
involve figuring out the one action
required to unlock whichever door is
needed to progress maybe you missed a
key item off the beaten track or maybe
it's a matter of trial and error or
maybe you're just overthinking it and
there's a much simpler solution that you
just haven't seen yet one example
- asks you with manipulating a large
stone pillar to cast light-sensitive
switches in shallow to open a cave door
once I triggered a mid puzzle cutscene
featuring a giant enemy bird
I spent a further 15 minutes fiddling
with the pillar only to realize that I'd
not seen a tiny ledge that allowed me to
climb out these hidden solutions make
the process of figuring out the puzzles
frustrating and the one step victory
hallo
Rhymes poor signposting carries through
to its exploration segment which often
left me clueless as to where to head
next Ryan doesn't have any consistent
goals like journeys shining mountain
with which to orientate yourself and my
cluelessness was made worse by the
repetitive world design each level has
its own theme first is a sunny island
the second a sandy desert the third an
abandoned city and the fourth a rainy
abyss but within each world there isn't
much architectural diversity and the
game does little to explore each theme
in interesting ways I was constantly
ambling forward not really knowing where
I was going or why and this is reflected
in the emotional journey that Ryan has
you follow the story is told through a
series of flashbacks but the abstract
nature of both the world and its lack of
language when it was never clear what my
driving force was I was playing for
progresses sake rather than because I
was desperate to turn the next page in a
story I was really engaged in two
threads that rhyme does lay down or a
hooded figure dressed in red and a
strange magical Fox but these are never
properly resolved and the ending is as
confusing as it is pretentious the twist
introduced that the story's close also
comes far too late to inject the
emotional weight the game sorely needed
up until that point there's no real
struggle little bonding time with other
characters no huge sense of loss not
many moments of elation making this
emotional roller coaster more of a
monotonous merry-go-round
[Music]
rhymes artistry is unquestionable each
world is enchanting in its own way from
the naturalistic peace of the first to
the abstract doom of the last its
soundtrack is similarly beautiful
capable of evoke in wonder tension and
fear in equal measure
[Music]
but when compared to its influences like
ICO Shadow of the Colossus and journey
rhyme doesn't hold up too well
consistent navigation problems coupled
with some frustrating puzzles and severe
framerate dips make Ryan feel like a
well dressed tribute act
[Music]
you
[Music]
you